there's not a lot you could say about
far cry 4 that you couldn't say about
far cry 3 where the previous two sequels
signaled significant changes in approach
far cry 4 takes its predecessor and
cranks everything up by several orders
of magnitude to make your own fun
sandbox is even more outrageous the
amount of pure stuff to do is endless
and the off-putting story and dialogue
are even greater blights big turn offs
in a game that doesn't know when enough
is enough
in other words far cry 4 takes every
element of every major Ubisoft series
and shoves them into one game and as you
can imagine it's big and crazy and
entertaining and problematic all at once
one Ubisoft big-budget calling card is
blatant faux edginess of which Far Cry 4
has plenty the over-the-top tension
actually starts off in a promising
manner introducing you right away to
pagan min the dictator of the Himalayan
nation of ki raat you're there to
scatter your mother's ashes he's there
to make your life a living hell
the brutal scenes that introduced men
are horrifying he's vain vindictive and
wholly lacking in empathy he then
disappears for most of the games leaving
you instead with a series of stereotypes
each one more embarrassing than the last
every so often the game seems to be
poised to make a point about you being a
gun-toting American shooting up soldiers
in the name of peace and freedom but
when you spend so much time instead
listening to a radio personality that
fantasizes about becoming a serial
killer that smears feces on his victims
it's difficult not to cringe there's not
much treasure to be found in this trash
it's when far cry 4 lets you off the
leash that you find the thrills you seek
you grab a few guns maybe a bow and
arrow maybe some molotovs and rush into
the wilds seeking to disrupt the land in
the name of the Golden Path Freedom
Fighters infiltrating outposts remains a
highlight and while the stealthy method
of doing so is still available to you
Far Cry 4s newest tools emphasized chaos
and destruction
you can throw a bit of meat and a bear
or a tiger will roar into the fray
lunging into your victims so you don't
have to get your shoes bloody you can
mount an elephant and charge forward
launching soldiers into the air with a
swipe of it strongly you can summon a
friendly to your side and set the place
ablaze with flamethrowers or assassinate
an artillery gunner and take over for
him dropping ordnance on the most
heavily armored baddies or instead of
summoning an AI comrade you can invite a
friend and get cooperatively
rambunctious if the helicopter is
proving pesky try getting in one of the
new gyrocopters and having your buddy
hang from beneath you maneuver into a
place and he shotguns the pilot in the
face why use a simple rocket launcher
when you can find more dramatic ways to
create explosions venture beyond
outposts you find even more ways to
express your violent tendencies the new
auto driving feature which allows you to
automate your trip towards your Waypoint
isn't very reliable but it does make it
easy to lob grenades on pursuing enemies
when you're behind the wheel you
liberate entire forts graphical edges
and climb upwards coasts quickly from
cliffs to valleys by activating your
wingsuit and unlock new areas by
climbing radio towers and hacking them
the map is dotted with boundless
activities to pursue in that Ubisoft way
and if those possibilities aren't
appealing enough you can always check
out the competitive multiplayer which
pits two asymmetrical teams against each
other one team can go invisible Colin
attack bears and ride elephants the
other accesses a full arsenal of weapons
and vehicles attempting to dominate by
pure show of force competitive play is
one more entertaining way of spending
your time in Far Cry 4 a game already
full of opportunities to make your own
one of farcry 4's biggest problems
however is that it doesn't trust you to
find that fun the games constant
reminders to go do something other than
the thing you're doing right now are
beyond here it's aiding you liberate an
outpost drive away and in ten seconds
you're alerted that the outpost is under
attack again and so you drive back and
fend off attackers leave and get the
same message again again the game will
even move your Waypoint on your behalf
and thus change your auto drive
destination when it decides what it
wants is more important than what you
want Far Cry 4 is needy it constantly
hounds you not just by an interface but
through entire gameplay systems the
gameplay suffers from other problems to
show up at a story mission and discover
you don't have the best weapons for the
job well going back to re-equip yourself
will force you to talk to the mission
giver again watch the same cutscenes
again and start everything from scratch
and there's no escaping far cry 3
when Far Cry 4s missions are sometimes
so blatantly similar
windows don't do drugs really when the
game is brilliant it's noticeably
brilliant the way its economy encourages
you to go hunt the wildlife and craft
new wallets and loot bags for carrying
more money and items the way it dangles
even more weapons in front of you making
you wonder how you might get even more
naughty the way it tempts you into every
nook and cranny Far Cry 4 like the
terrain it depicts goes very high and
very low the lows are downright scornful
yet the highs are sometimes breathtaking
it's awesome and messy and dumb and fun
and problematic and gross and beautiful
take any given adjective in your
vocabulary and chances are something in
Far Cry 4 can be described that way
you